The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK.
Let me just say our next
topic, moving really
toward machine
learning, would be
the last section
of chapter 6 about
stochastic gradient descent.
I think Professor Sra
from computer science,
if he is able, he will take
the class Friday and tell us
about SGDs, Stochastic Gradient
Descent, critical algorithm.
I mean that, at a quick look,
stochastic gradient descent
does smaller batches at a time,
so it's computationally faster
than pure gradient descent.
But also, stochastic
gradient descent
is able to solve
probabilistic problems where
you're trying to minimize
an expected value instead
of a function.
Anyway, it's an important thing.
Actually, there is
a lecture at 2:00
in neuroscience about the
gradient descent algorithms.
And then Professor Boyd
is speaking here at 4:30
this afternoon.
It's overwhelming.
So I'm going to talk today
about several topics that are
specific parts of optimization.
Linear programming is a very
famous part of optimization.
I don't know if you've met it.
I think it's worth knowing
what the inputs are
and what's the key fact
about linear programming.
And, of course, also,
what are the algorithms.
That's usually what
we want to know.
What's the problem?
What are the results,
the mathematical results?
And what are the
computational tools?
Yes, so that's very established.
Max-flow min-cut is one
specific linear programming
that I think maybe would
serve as the best example.
And then two-person
games, have you met those?
So would you know
what the rules are
in a two-person zero-sum game?
In game theory, those are
the ones that are clear--
everything's
well-established there.
And, in fact, they're
equivalent to a linear program.
So that's why those two
are coming in today.
And then the key fact about
two-person games and about
linear programming is duality.
So if there's any
word on that board,
it's the one in capital
letters that has math content.
I'm just going to start
with linear programming
and then move on.
So what's a linear program?
It's we're optimizing
a linear cost function.
So we're minimizing
the cost c transpose x.
So that vector x is the
unknown that we're looking for,
and this vector c
is the cost vector.
So that is c1 x1
plus, plus cn xn.
So you can see why it's
called linear programming.
The cost is linear.
The constraints are also linear.
So the constraints on x are
a set of linear equations.
Of course, I'm not thinking of
A as being a square invertible
matrix.
No way.
If it were, that would
tell us what x had to be
and our problem would be over.
We have n unknowns.
This is m by n, of course.
x is n by 1.
That's our unknown vector.
And I'm thinking that m
would be smaller than n.
But we do have
constraints, and now comes
the thing that makes linear
programming not actually
linear.
And that's the constraint
x greater or equal to 0.
And I've written
that as a vector
but that means x1 greater
or equal to 0, on to xn
greater or equal to 0.
So it's a vector inequality.
So we have minimizing
a very simple function
with pretty straightforward
constraints but inequality
constraints.
So the set of--
these two together
are the constraints.
And in linear algebra--
in linear programming language
this is called a feasible set
of x's.
It's the constraint set,
capital K in the notes.
So let me draw a
picture to show--
or maybe I'll just ask.
How many of you are
already familiar
with linear programming?
Oh, quite a lot.
So I won't belabor the point.
But let me just draw a picture.
So my picture will be just here.
So that's n equals 3.
So this is the x1, x2, x3 space.
And x greater or
equal to 0 means what?
It means that I'm in this
1/8 of this space, right?
It's the non-negative--
well, I would say quadrant
but I really should
say octant because it's
1/8 of the full 3D space.
So I'm in here.
And then maybe I have m as
maybe just one constraint.
So let me take the cost to be,
say, x1 plus 2 x2 plus 5 x3,
say.
And the constraint, I'm just
going to have one equation--
x1 plus x2.
Let me make it easy, make that
constraint an easy one to--
so this is what we
want to minimize.
And that's what we have
to satisfy, as well
as x greater or equal to 0.
So that's a plane.
One equation gives
us a plane in R3.
The plane would go through--
would hit the axes at 3, 0, 0.
And so the min--
the point has to
lie on that plane.
And it has to lie in the octant,
so that plane is chopped off
to be a triangle.
This is a good visualization
of linear programming.
And what's the conclusion?
Well, our cost is linear.
So the result is that one
of these three corners
is the winner.
It could happen.
It could happen that maybe I
have equal values on those two
corners, and therefore
all the way along
would be also winners.
But when I have a
linear function,
it's a maximum at the ends.
And these are the ends,
those three corners.
So 3, 0, 0, 0, 3, 0, or 0,
0, 3 are the three corners,
and one of those is the winner
and the problem is solved.
And, in fact, for this
case, since I'm minimizing,
I guess it would be
that corner that wins.
So let me give it
a star, not an x.
Yes.
3, 0, 0 because that--
oh.
No, that's 3.
So the value turned out to
be 3 at the point 3, 0, 0.
And that's x star.
Good.
Good, good, good.
What more do I
want to do, I said?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't it
be at point 0, 0, 3?
GILBERT STRANG: Should it be--
oh, no.
0, 0, 3 would have x3 is 3.
That's fine.
It gives us a chance, I think.
That would give me a cost of 15.
This would give me a
cost of 6, and that
would give me a cost of 3.
Yes.
It's obvious that if we could
enumerate all the corners,
we would have a super fast
way to get the answer.
But the trouble is, of course,
that for large values of m
and n, there are
exponentially many corners,
and we don't want
to see them all.
So that's what makes linear
programming take time and need
ideas.
So, for algorithms,
there are two types
of algorithms, two types
of codes that solve these.
The older, well-established
ones are the--
so one way is the simplex
method, which finds a corner.
We know the optimum
one of the corners.
So it will find one corner, and
it will go to the next corner.
So if it starts at
one of these corners,
it will travel along an
edge that lowers the cost.
And it has to stop at the
end because it's linear.
The cost will keep going
down and going down
until it bumps
into the end point,
and then it can't go further.
And then we would, from
that next corner, we
would go to the next corner.
Each time, it's like steepest
descent on the edges.
From the first corner,
we go the steepest way
till we can't go further,
we've hit another corner.
And we recompute
the linear algebra,
find which direction
is steepest from there.
So that's the idea of
the simplex method,
which was invented by Dantzig.
And the algebra is not going
to be in today's lecture
but it's straightforward.
Well, people have to
optimize it because that's
a highly frequently used method.
Yes.
But then, about 20 years
later maybe, or 30, I
remember going to a lecture in
downtown Boston by Karmarkar.
So I have to put his name down--
Karmarkar.
And he was in The New York
Times, all the newspapers,
so it was a big deal.
He had an alternative algorithm.
And the exact
algorithm he proposed
hasn't survived until
today but the idea has.
And the idea was to go to travel
inside the feasible set and not
around the edges.
So his idea-- because
in here, would maybe
travel down near that edge,
start again, travel again.
So it's steepest descent in the
constraint set, the feasible
set.
And you can use
calculus and this idea.
So this is interior
point method.
So I'll just use
the word interior.
That's telling us that we're
inside the feasible set.
We don't hit, come all
the way to the boundary
intentionally,
because we want room
to move, and to find
derivatives, and to use
Newton's method to minimize.
You choose a search direction,
just as all of optimization
does.
And in that search
direction, you
track it and you
stop before you bump
into the edge of
the feasible set.
And then you compute
derivatives again.
So you can use calculus.
And it's a method that--
it's an idea that--
the interior idea
came before Karmarkar.
But he got super publicity,
so it really got attention,
got new thinking.
And new ideas came partly
from people at MIT.
And these two are now still
locked in competition.
One hasn't beaten the
other in all problems.
So linear programming is here.
But then, for
nonlinear programming,
quadratic programming,
where the cost is quadratic,
nonlinear programming,
semi-definite programming--
that's where you have a
matrix unknown and matrix
constraints--
those are all-- the more
complicated you get,
the more it tends to be
interior point methods.
That's a summary of
linear programming.
Now I'd like to give an example.
And then I haven't
told you the main--
well, let me tell you the
main fact about duality.
This is really-- and I'll write
that maybe here next to it.
So duality is there's a
dual program, a dual LP.
And that dual is going to do
a maximum instead of a minimum
And the cost is going to involve
the b from the primal problem.
So this is now called the primal
problem, and this is its dual.
So they're twin problems.
They use the same data
but quite differently.
It's like transposing things.
So let's call it the unknown y.
So for y1 to ym, I guess,
because b, the right-hand side
over here, is m by 1.
So that's maximize that subject
to-- what are the constraints?
Well, the cost function over
here, c, the cost vector,
goes into the constraints.
And I think the greater or
equal sign probably becomes
a less or equal to sign.
The A gets transposed.
I think that's probably
the constraint in the dual.
And it happens it
doesn't need y.
We don't have y greater
or equal to 0 over here.
So that's a dual problem.
It has a linear cost.
It has linear
inequality constraints.
It can be solved by
the simplex method.
You could choose whether you
solve that one or this one,
because if you solve
one, you solve the other.
The two are closely
connected and that's
the key idea of duality.
So maybe I'll put the idea of,
first of all, a weak duality.
Which says that this quantity
that we're trying to maximize--
we're getting it as
large as possible--
is always less or equal
to any c transpose x.
This is for any
feasible, allowed--
any x and y that
satisfy the constraints.
Remember, feasible means
satisfies the constraints.
So, in other words, this
problem, this maximization
problem, you're trying
to push this up.
The minimization problem,
you're trying to pull this down.
And it's easier to show
that the one, the b
transpose-- it's easier
to show that inequality.
Let's do that.
So b transpose y proof.
It should be a one-line proof.
So b transpose y--
what do I do?
So b transpose y well,
I look over here.
That's where b shows up.
That's x transpose A
transpose y, because b is Ax.
I'm feasible, so my b is Ax.
And for any x-- this
is for this is for any
x that b is going to be Ax.
So am I good so far?
And now what do I do?
Now I look here.
I see A transpose y sitting
right in front of me.
So I say, well, OK,
less or equal to.
And I guess I'm done.
A transpose y is
less or equal to c.
So I have x transpose
c, c transpose x.
So this equals this,
less or equal that.
I've got it.
Weak duality is just put
together the requirements
on x and y and you have it.
But was this important?
If the mathematics
is right, everything
has to have its
place, play its role.
And so what's the role of x
greater or equal to 0 there?
Why do we need x--
If we just even think of
n equal 1, just a number,
where do we use the fact that
x is greater or equal to 0?
Do we use it?
This looks so smooth,
because A transpose y--
I'll write that as x
transpose c for the moment,
just so your eye says
that's the same x transpose,
and the A transpose y
is less or equal to c.
Where is x greater or
equal to 0 coming in?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GILBERT STRANG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Like above.
It's from the that.
GILBERT STRANG:
Yes, that's true.
But I want to see--
so here's my point.
The fact that A
transpose y is less
or equal to c, that's fine.
Highly important.
But if x was negative, it
would be the other way.
You would go the
other way and you
wouldn't have what you want.
So we really do use the fact
that x is greater or equal to 0
to say that I have this
less or equal this.
And then I multiply
by something positive
and then I still
have less or equal.
OK, good.
So the math is right.
Everything does its part.
And then, of course,
the beautiful result,
the important
result is that there
is strong duality,
just called duality,
which is that at the maximum--
now this is not for any
x and y but this is for--
this is going to be for
x y star, the winner,
and x star, the winner--
equality holds.
So that's duality.
The maximum in the
dual problem is
the same as the minimum
in the primal problem.
The two have met.
There is no duality gap.
In some cooked up
nonlinear problems,
there could be a gap between
the maximum and the minimum,
but you hope not.
And here the big theorem is not.
They're equal.
You push this up,
push that down.
Another way to say that
duality is that this is
pushing that up at some max--
I could write that as a maximum
of a minimum equaling a minimum
of a maximum, if I wanted.
So the duality in
linear programming
was the same as von
Neumann's minimax theorem.
And his theorem applied
to two-person games.
So the key math result is
duality for linear programming,
and it's going to be-- you'll
see the same thing happening
for two-person games.
And it's a minimax
theorem, or a saddle point.
Or it's just things
come out right.
Yes.
So just to mention that
mathematical programming,
of course, includes much
more difficult problems.
This is linear programming.
That problem, as you see, has
a beautiful, simple theory.
And the paying attention
is paying attention
to the algorithm, because
you've got two important choices
and they both get
highly developed.
Now, OK.
So for game, now I'm
going to turn to--
well, I'll do an example
of max flow equal min cut,
just see what--
and then go to two-person game.
So here's an example of a--
so I start with a graph.
Let me just imagine.
So this is the source.
This is the sink.
And I'm sending flow
through the network.
So it's a network that
I'm sending flow through.
So my job is to maximize--
I'll set x at the
source to be 0.
And then the flow, the total
flow will come into the sink.
So I want to maximize
x at the sink.
So it's a linear programming
and there are constraints.
So what are the constraints?
Every edge has a capacity.
So let's see.
Suppose that edge
has capacity 5.
Let me put capacities
on all these edges.
2, 1, 3, 4.
I'm just stabbing around here.
1,000.
And let me say 2 and 4.
I have no idea what's
happening here.
But if we see the problem, we'll
probably be able to solve it.
So these constraints are
that the flow variable,
which would be the y that I'm
trying to maximize, cannot--
the amount of flow,
just in ordinary words,
the amount of flow on
the edges can't go higher
than the capacity.
I could send 11 along this
edge, but then I've got nowhere
to send it after that.
I could send, well,
900 on that edge.
but, obviously, it
would get stuck there.
So the question is,
what's the maximum I
can send through that network?
It's a classical problem.
And, in fact, it's an
integer programming problem.
These are all
integer capacities.
I could insist on integer flow.
But it's a very
remarkable integer problem
because I could allow
fractions and the answer
would not be a-- would
not involve fractions.
In other words, if I keep
it as an integer problem,
then the mathematics
is definitely
harder for an integer problem.
What's different?
So the x's could be integers
or they could be real numbers.
Over here, they
were real numbers.
I happened to get
an integer for this,
but if I had 10 crossing
planes in 15 dimensions,
the integers would
be totally lost.
But the point is, here, that
if I allow real numbers,
it doesn't get me any more
flow, that the winning
flow is an integer anyway.
So it's an integer problem
which can be safely relaxed,
and you can safely use simplex
method, or Karmarkar's method,
or any interior point
method with non-integers,
because in the interior here
you're not starting or ending
at integers.
You can do it because
the integer answer
will be, in the end, better.
And what is that answer?
I think I've made those
capacities too easy to--
oh, I didn't do this one.
So what shall I-- shall
I make it large, like 9?
I don't know.
What's the best we can
do through that network?
Can you-- I can't
see it from here yet?
What should I do?
Obviously, in this
simple problem
I can get anything I want
pretty much that far.
But then what can I do?
Let me even make that 19.
So I'm not imposing much of
a limit on that edge either.
But these edges are
quite tight limits,
and these are sort of
intermediate limits.
What do you think is the
most I can send through?
And how would you show me
that I couldn't send more?
That's the key question.
I want to get a bound on the--
an upper bound on this maximum.
This maximum getting
into the sink
is less or equal to-- and
what number would you propose?
Could I get 1,000 through?
I could start, but of course
it would pile up there.
I couldn't get further.
What do you think is
the best I can do?
AUDIENCE: 10?
GILBERT STRANG: 10?
I can't do more than 10?
How could I do 10?
AUDIENCE: So you go 12--
GILBERT STRANG: 12 this way?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
19.
GILBERT STRANG: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: And then
split the 8 and 2.
Can you split?
GILBERT STRANG: I see.
10 that way, 10 this-- yes,
absolutely you can split.
And then this could go here, and
that would be able to go there.
So I can get 10 through.
Correct.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GILBERT STRANG: Can
I do anything better?
Oh, I could be sending some
up this way at the same time.
So I could get 3 along the top.
So this is like an auction.
We can get up to 13.
Can we get-- so that was 3 going
this way and 10 going this way.
Is 13 an-- can I not exceed 13?
AUDIENCE: 14?
AUDIENCE: 14.
GILBERT STRANG: Do I hear 14?
Oh, I've got a lot
of room for one more.
So, OK.
So 14 in any case.
All right.
Do I hear 15?
AUDIENCE: Can you do
two more on the bottom,
like 12 instead of 10?
GILBERT STRANG: If I did
12, then what would I do?
AUDIENCE: Split
the other two up.
GILBERT STRANG: I'd
send two up here.
What am I going to do
with them from here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GILBERT STRANG: Send them?
AUDIENCE: Up again.
GILBERT STRANG: Up
again, and along.
But then the 3 that I had right
now would be cut back to 1.
It's a lot of fun,
this max flow problem.
And I'm looking
for a bound to know
when to quit, to know
when I've optimized.
That's the whole
idea of duality,
is to find some upper thing
that I'm trying to push down
but I can't go beyond it.
So I don't think I
could get more than--
you see, everything has
to cross this middle.
So 3 and 4.
And I don't think
I could beat 23.
If somebody said more than
23, I would be very doubtful,
because I couldn't get
it across the middle.
But then, can I get 23?
I doubt it.
Maybe 14 is the best possible.
So how would we show that
14 is the best possible?
I think if I could find--
so this is called a cut,
a cut in this network.
Oh, yes, I see a cut.
A cut like there.
You see that?
Every bit of flow has
got to cross that cut.
And the total capacity crossing
is the 3 and the 1 and the 2
and the 8, which is 14.
So I can't get more
than 14 through.
And somehow that cut
is loaded to capacity.
Probably those edges
all have to be fully up
to capacity that cross the cut.
So the cut is a
separation of edges
that go with the source and--
sorry-- nodes that go
with the source, nodes
that go with the sink.
Yes.
And then it's the
edges across the cut.
Is that OK for an example?
So that's the duality.
The maximum flow
turned out to be 14,
and the minimum cut
turned out to be 14.
And when those match, 14
equal 14, I know I'm through.
I know I'm through because
I'm able to get 14 through
and I could never get more.
Yes.
3 and 4 and 6 and 8.
And, of course,
in a big network,
the maximum cut is not
going to be visible.
Well, you couldn't-- it would
have thousands of edges.
You couldn't see
what you were doing,
But you could solve this
problem fast, actually fast.
And it's an important--
in practice, it's an
important example.
A lot of other things fit into
the max flow min cut example.
And therefore solving
it in faster than-- oh,
I didn't even say about speed.
So the simplex method, almost
always it's average case.
Dan Spielman, who
was on the faculty
here, who's just
terrific in this area,
was maybe among the first
to study the average case.
So for an average
choice of A and b and c,
instead of making
the worst choice--
for the worst choice, you
can create a feasible set
that it has to go
corner, corner, corner,
corner to get to the end,
so the simplex method would
take exponentially long.
But that's extremely rare.
It doesn't happen in
practice, I think.
And the average one
is a polynomial,
so it's a fast
method on average.
And we can show-- actually,
that was a famous result that
came from Russia, that linear
programming is in the big P
versus LP world,
linear programming
goes with P. Linear
programming is
a problem that can be
solved in polynomial time.
The simplex method won't always
do it but it can be done.
Yes.
There came into the world,
the ellipsoid methods,
and it was an exciting time to
decide that linear programming
was actually P and not LP.
So this is a case of duality
where you can understand
duality by the statement
that the flow cannot exceed
the capacity of the cut.
So that's what duality
is, that any flow has
to be less or equal the
capacity of any cut,
the capacity being
the sum of the ones.
So, of course, there
are other cuts.
That cut has to be
crossed, but that's
gone 3, 7, 14, 22 capacity.
So the 14 capacity
was the minimum,
and that gave the maximum.
Nice.
Isn't it nice?
Yes.
So there is another world
here of two-person games
that also has duality
and could be expressed.
So let me just talk finally
today about two-person games.
So the two persons
are x and y of course.
What other names
could they have?
And there is a matrix involved.
This is the payoff matrix.
So let me take a very
simple game first.
So x is going to choose
one of these rows,
and y is going to choose
one of these columns.
And let's say
payoff from x to y.
I like it that way because,
then, x, who's paying,
is going to be minimizing,
as x was up here.
And y, who's
collecting, is going
to be maximizing,
as in the dual.
So the payoff-- well, let's see.
I think maybe 1, 4, 2, 8 would
be probably a fairly easy game
to play.
So it's a two-person
game, a zero-sum game.
Zero sum means--
that means all pay--
what x pays goes to y.
y gets all that x pays.
There's no third party here.
No lawyers involved.
And y is going to
choose a column,
and x is going to choose a row.
And x wants to make it small,
and y wants to make it big.
So what happens in this game?
What does y choose
to make it big?
The second column.
What does x choose
to make it small?
The first row.
So it's going to be
focused in on that 2,
because if y keeps choosing
that column, 2 is the best--
the least that-- x is
going to have to pay 2,
and he achieves that by
choosing the first row.
So it's a simple game.
That's a saddle point.
It's a minimum for
y in its column,
and it's a maximum
for x in its row.
But, of course, a
matrix, another matrix
might not have such
a saddle point.
So let me-- do you see--
OK with this game?
That would be a sort
of straightforward game
where simple strategy--
column 2 every time, row 1
every time is the optimal.
But now let me
just exchange that.
So, again, x1 and x2.
y1 and y2 are the two columns.
What happens now?
Well, y kind of likes
the big number 8 there.
So it goes for the second.
The second column still
has the bigger numbers.
So y aims for column 2.
But then what does x do?
What row does x choose
if y is in the column 2?
AUDIENCE: Second.
GILBERT STRANG: The second.
OK.
So have I found a saddle point?
Where y chooses this
column, x chooses this row,
is that a saddle point?
No.
Because what will y do now?
He sees x choosing the
second row all the time,
and y sees a 4, a very
tempting 4, in that row.
So y is going to choose y1,
the first column, pretty often.
Not all the time, because
what happens if he just--
if y chooses this
column all the time,
then x will choose
this row and the payoff
would only be 1, so that things
went downhill for y there.
So this is not a saddle point.
And what do we do?
Mixed strategy, which is y
will choose the two columns
with some probabilities
that add to 1.
So there will be a third
possibility, that p x1 and 1--
I'm sorry-- p y1.
p times this column and 1 minus
p times the second column.
So that will be p plus 1
minus p times 8, and 4p plus 1
minus p times 2.
That's this mixed column.
By mixing his strategy,
we have a strategy
like a third person, y3.
And, of course, the x is going
to notice after a while what
the strategy is.
This is an open competition.
You're not hiding-- you're
not able to hide anything.
You might think, well,
maybe y will jump around,
but that's foolishness.
y is going to end
up finding the best
choice of p between 0 and 1.
And it will actually
be between 0 and 1
because the extreme strategies
of column 1 and column 2
were not winners.
But now x is going
to do the same thing.
p x1-- he's going to--
he or she is going to
combine those rows.
So this would be p1 for
the first row, and 1--
sorry-- p-- oh, I better
choose another number.
What's another letter than p?
AUDIENCE: q.
GILBERT STRANG: q?
OK, q.
So this row is a combination
of those rows, so it's q plus 1
minus q times 4 in the first
position, and p times 8 and 1
minus p-- q times 8.
q times 8 and 1 minus q times 2.
I'm sorry that I've
written this too small.
But what's going to happen?
What's going to determine
p and q and solve the game?
Well, if these are
equal, then what happens?
Then x is OK with either one.
x has nothing to choose
if those are equal
and y is staying with his
mixed strategy, which gives him
this third combination column.
Then x is good.
Now, you might say, well, then
x could do what it wanted.
But x couldn't do
what it wanted.
If x doesn't stick with the
optimal strategy q for x,
then y will take advantage.
So, really, the game
settles down to once--
so these should be equal.
So when those are
equal, what do I get?
I have p-- it looks
like I have 8 minus 7p
there for the first one.
And here, I have 4p minus 2p.
That's 2p plus 1.
Did I get that possibly right?
AUDIENCE: Plus 2.
GILBERT STRANG: 2, 4p
minus 2p is the 2p.
Oh, it's 2.
Yes.
OK.
So those are equal.
And that tells me that
9p is 6, and p is 2/3.
So it turned out that
the best strategy for y
is 2/3 on the first column
which didn't look so promising,
and 1/3 on the second column.
And by creating that strategy,
what do these numbers come out
to be?
And they're supposed
to come out equal.
So 4p plus-- so 4
times 2/3 is 8/3,
plus 1 minus p is 1/3 times--
plus 2/3 is 10/3.
So I think that this is 10/3.
And if that one isn't
10/3, I'm very surprised.
So that's 2/3-- help.
Is it?
4p, 2p, 4/3.
Yes, it's telling
me they're the same.
Did I set them equal?
Yes.
I set them equal to find p.
So they have to be the same.
Except for instructor mistakes,
which never happen, I suppose.
OK.
So those should be equal.
Then x has no way to do
better, choose these columns.
But he can't choose
those columns freely--
those rows freely because y
could take advantage, unless--
so this would give the
best strategy for q--
sorry-- the best q for x.
Yes.
Do you see that picture now?
There could be other--
it could be a much
bigger matrix, of course.
There could be other columns.
Suppose there was a 0, 0 column.
What difference-- what
would be the effect
on the optimal strategy of
having that additional column,
that additional option for y3?
Well, he wouldn't take it.
So let's make it more tempting.
10, 10, 10.
Oh, he would take that, right?
Yes.
That was not-- so I'm not sure
what I am trying to say here.
Yes.
There certainly could be--
there could be rows that--
or columns, or rows for x,
that don't enter the mixed,
the optimal mixed strategy.
A mixed strategy
is some combination
of strategies, some
combination of pure strategies,
like choose this
column, choose this row.
But some columns may
not-- or rows-- may not
show up in the best mixture.
So I won't complete that
partial thought there.
So do you see that we
have a duality theorem?
First of all, you could write
that as a linear program.
The unknown is p for x--
for y.
The unknown is q for x.
So, actually, you just have one
unknown in this simple problem,
for this small problem.
But you have a minimization,
a maximization.
They meet at the optimum.
And the duality theorem
becomes the theorem
for two-person games.
Linear programming
matches two-person games.
The point about two
persons is very important.
Three-person games are
incredibly complicated.
No theory at this simple level
would solve three-person games.
So that's where John
Nash's Nobel Prize
comes into the picture.
So his Nobel Prize
was in economics
because of the
wide applications,
but he was able to
analyze the problem of--
and for functions more
than for matrices--
of a three-person
or n-person game.
So you know the
story of John Nash?
The book A Beautiful Mind and
the movie A Beautiful Mind.
So it's one of those
movies that involves MIT
because he was here.
But you can't recognize
anything about MIT in the movie.
It's like Good Will Hunting.
You're maybe in some basement
of some remote building.
But anyway.
It was of course a tragic--
tragic, and then cheer, then
wonderful, and then tragic
again for John Nash.
He had-- so when
I met him, he was
going to teach linear
algebra, one section,
but that never developed.
That was when he was--
his mental state
was going downhill.
And he moved to Princeton
and just stayed.
And then the wonderful
thing was that he improved,
and then the very sad
thing was his death
in a car accident on the way
home from the Nobel Prize.
So quite a story,
an amazing story.
Yes.
So that's specific optimization
problems, linear programming
and two-person games.
And I hope that Friday it
will be Professor Sra. Anyway,
the lecture will certainly
be about stochastic gradient
descent.
Good.
Thanks.